génique c'est aujourd'hui que claude
allègre présente son plan université du
troisième millénaire l'occasion de faire
le bilan du plan précédent université
2000 qui avait été lancé en 1990 c'était
un programme ambitieux avec pour
objectif de fournir des locaux modernes
et d'insérer l'université dans la ville
aujourd'hui vous allez le voir le
résultat est quelque peu contrastée
reportage de jean pellieux et josé
boulesteix à aix-en-provence bordé par
un boulevard d'accès au centre-ville ces
bâtiments abritent la nouvelle
université d'aix
c'est dans l'un des quartiers ouest un
quartier de logements essentiellement
des hlm qui est implantée la maison
méditerranéenne des sciences de l'homme
le nom exact de l'établissement
méditerranée le ton est donné dès
l'entrée avec ce grand jardin inspiré de
celui de grenade en espagne
jeux de lumière aussi l étage dans la
bibliothèque d'archéologique accueil sur
deux niveaux chercheurs et étudiants du
troisième cycle de l'autre côté de cette
terrasse l'ale des chercheurs ponctuée
de patients ont rafraîchi l'été par
l'eau des bassins espace fermé espace
ouvert un mariage apprécié des
utilisateurs personne est enfermé sur
soi même c'est à la fois l'intimité et
l'ouverture sur nos disciplines et s'ils
donnent la possibilité que le chercheur
d'accéder partout
l'université accueille 200 chercheurs en
sciences sociales et en archéologie et
250 étudiants avec tous le même secteur
d'activité le monde méditerranéen
la plupart travaillé jusqu'ici dans des
bâtiments exigu installé dans le centre
ancien d'aix-en-provence
une proximité entre les enseignants et
les étudiants
le fait que ce qu'annonçait centre de
recherche et ya rayah de bibliothèques
s'adonnent à fait ça donne une autre
image de la vie tu te trouves faisant le
travail
ouais ouais vachement plus autour de ce
bâtiment il n'y a pratiquement que des
hlm
c'est un nouveau quartier à votre avis
tout ça va bien ensemble comme ça mais
moi ça me dérange pas du tout au
contraire
là on en change en le changeant
environnement
et quand je pense pas que ça soit gênant
pour nous ni pour eux ni pour les gens
qui vivent ici c'est le contraire d'un
campus
ouais vraiment le contraire principales
zones d'expansion de la ville le
quartier accueille aujourd'hui 20% de la
population aixoise donc une majorité de
familles très modestes
les associations viennent à lorraine
notamment pour le soutien scolaire
les accompagnateurs sont des retraités
ou des étudiants venus d'autres
quartiers mais personne de l'université
sur place ici on est déçus il faut que
peut-être lui laisser du temps
mais s'il est vrai que le mouvement pour
sortir un petit peu de sites et d'aller
vers la ville ouvert le quartier ne
s'est pas encore fait oui on fore des
intellectuels oublieux des jeunes
déshérités une situation qui ne plaît à
personne
les habitants eux espèrent que d'ici
l'an 2000 l'université se montrera
solidaires de leur quartier par mille